bonjour nous sommes le jeudi 5 mars
merci de nous retrouver dans silico
l'émission qui revient sur l'actualité
économique locale
avec aujourd'hui une émission spéciale
dédiée aux femmes et à leur situation et
le monde professionnel et de
l'entreprise on commence ensuite avec
les titres de cette édition
dans l'actualité de cette semaine suite
du dossier promo paul le directeur
othman masque on accuse l'ancienne
présidence et direction de la pépinière
d'entreprises
l'affairé portée devant le tribunal de
commerce cette semaine nous nous
intéressons métier d'archiviste entre
conservateurs et l'enquêteur découvrez
ce métier passionnant
enfin l'entreprise la semaine s'appelle
in expats elle aide les expatriés à
s'installer sur le territoire créé en
2009 par une illinois de la société est
en plein développement
et cette semaine à l'occasion de la
journée de la femme qui a lu je le
rappelle le 8 mars nous recevons quatre
invités sur notre plateau un plateau
exclusivement féminin pour parler des
femmes dans le monde de l'entreprise
bonjour avocate mesdames nous sommes
avec axel qu'hormis vous êtes juriste et
intervenez pour le cidf cidff 78 donc le
centre d'information sur les droits des
femmes et les familles elisabeth traces
de loup vous travaillez également pour
le cidff 60,18 vous êtes conseillère
emploi au service des femmes et agathe
rob lowe et caroline leblanc vous êtes
deux créatrices et entrepreneur vous
allez répondre à nos questions et
partagerez vos expériences personnelles
sur la situation de la femme dans le
monde professionnel mais dans leur
entreprise pardon mais avant cela
passons en revue l'actualité de la
semaine
le géant du nucléaire français vient
d'annoncer cette semaine des pertes
atomique pour 2014 4,8 milliards d'euros
détenu à 85% par l'état areva emploie
trente mille personnes dans l'hexagone
et 45000 à travers le monde
la multinationale est implanté depuis
1981 à saint quentin en yvelines
un millier de salariés sont employés sur
le site de montigny le bretonneux
eux aussi devraient être touchés par le
plan de restructuration
si le gouvernement souhaite éviter les
licenciements des départs volontaires
sont à minima obligatoires autre piste
évoquée par françois hollande emmanuel
macron le ministre de l'économie
une refonte du partenariat et même un
rapprochement capitalistique avec edf
sans transition promo paul assigne
l'ancienne direction devant le tribunal
de commerce de nanterre la semaine
dernière le président de la pépinière
othman menaceront a tenu une conférence
de presse
ainsi qu'une réunion avec les locataires
de promo paul afin d'expliquer cette
décision regardez le reportage d
imaginer et le diwan des actes de
gestion litigieux c'est ce que reproche
othman natrue à l'ancienne direction de
promo paul la pépinière d'entreprises
société d'économie mixte s'engage dans
une procédure judiciaire
suite aux conclusions d'un audit mené en
juin dernier audit qui avait souligné
des anomalies significatives au niveau
de la gestion l'entreprise du directeur
de propos du dernier directeur qui était
nommé en avril qu'a facturer des
prestations des prestations de type
conseil à la société donc effectivement
c'est là se pose la question d'un
mélange des genres parce que ses
prestations ont par ailleurs été
qualifié largement de fictives et puis
regard des montants qui ont été engagées
il s'agit au total d'un prêt 42000 euros
facturés en quatre mois alors que
proposait déjà plus face à ses échéances
bancaires pour l'entreprise et directeur
évidemment ça nous amène aujourd'hui à
demander le remboursement de ces sommes
selon othman nassr où l'entreprise aspar
pme à facturer un montant de 40 ans 1
1770 euros à promo paul pour des
prestations de conseils facture kottmann
natrue a suspendu à son arrivée on
février la pme a assigné en référé la
pépinière d'entreprises et lui réclame
encore 14000 euros
les prestations de cabinets de conseil
ce qu'on appelle les conventions
d'assistance dans lesquelles cette
entreprise intervenez mais sans que je
n'ai ni de rapports d'intervention ni de
contrôle ni de compte rendu de ses
interventions
c'était facturé 950 euros par jour pour
consultant un scandale pur othman nasri
mais qui ne semble pas inquiéter outre
mesure les entrepreneurs locataires de
l'établissement après la première
réunion d'information que nous avons eu
effectivement ça me surprend pas outre
mesure
'l'annonce me surprend pas maintenant
après le personnage ne connaissait pas
donc on n'est pas d'avis à donner là
dessus y a pas spécialement de problèmes
pour nous je pense pas que cela remette
en cause la fermeture ou pas alou la
continuité de promo paul selon certains
locataires les problèmes de gestion
seraient antérieurs à l'ancienne
présidence de monsieur jean yves gendron
nous l'avons contacté ainsi que le
directeur de sparte pme ils n'ont pas
donné suite à nos demandes
le département des yvelines se classe
10e au classement des départements les
mieux gérées de france à l'occasion des
départementales bfm business a publié
une enquête l'étude a passé au crible la
gestion des conseils généraux sortants
et le département s'en sort plutôt bien
les yvelines sont en tête du classement
sur le budget alloué au fonctionnement
en ne dépensant que 642 euros par
habitant elle se trouve elles sont aussi
en première place pour les dépenses
liées au personnel pour plus
d'informations retrouvez cette étude sur
le site internet de bfm business
le digital les applications ce parfum
smartphones sont en plein développement
et propose des solutions innovantes aux
tant pour les entreprises que pour les
collectivités territoriales c'était le
sujet de la réunion des entrepreneurs de
la plaine de versailles qui a lieu ce
mercredi à saint cyr l'école des images
signées williams l application mobile
géolocalisation et digital ce sont
autant de préoccupations pour les
entreprises l'ère numérique
un passage obligé qu'il ne faut pas
rater c'est pourquoi le club des
entrepreneurs de la plaine de versailles
en a fait le thème de sa réunion le
succès se fait par la différence donc si
on communique pas qu'on est bon dans un
tel ou tel truc qu'on fait du bon pain
qu'on fait de la bonne viande qu'on a
des bons bouquins qu'on est un bon
libraire ou qu'on ait un bar plutôt
sympa et bien c'est vrai qu'on n'y
arrive pas parce que nos territoires
sont étendus encore une fois
une problématique qui parle aux
entreprises mais aussi aux collectivités
territoriales la communication digitale
en moyens de dynamiser les territoires
de plus en plus de solutions existent
pour aider l'économie locale
c'est le cas des applications mobiles
présentés aujourd'hui comme sweeping une
application de géolocalisation
l'application vent public swing permet
aux professionnels d'envoyer de
l'information aux utilisateurs
lorsqu'ils passent à côté de deux points
d'intérêt qui seront définies ces points
d'intérêts peuvent être ces petites
balises notamment qui sont s'appelle
d'ebikon ces petites balises bluetooth
qui vont réveiller le smartphone
lorsqu'on passe à côté
concrètement les utilisateurs vont
télécharger l'application se balader
dans les centres villes dans les lieux
touristiques et culturelles et recevoir
avoir le téléphone réveiller recevoir
l'information en fonction de là où ils
sont si l'application n'est pas encore
développée dans le département elle
suscite déjà un certain intérêt pour
sincère ça pourrait être un plus pour
essayer de réveiller nos commerces qui
ont énormément de mal à vivre en ce
moment dans les yvelines plusieurs
mairies ont déjà leurs propres
applications comme elancourt ou repas un
nouveau moyen de tisser du lien et de
créer des échanges entre les pouvoirs
publics et les citoyens et il est
maintenant temps de retrouver nos
invités c'est l'heure de l'entretien de
la semaine
le 8 mars prochain c'est la journée de
la femme l'occasion de faire un point
sur la situation des femmes dans le
monde professionnel
pour cela nous sommes avec je le
rappelle accès le cormier qui est
juriste elizabeth pas de loup qui est
conseillère emploi au service des femmes
et agathe rob lowe et caroline leblanc
créatrice de la marque de sous-vêtements
bibi est vive et destiné aux femmes
atteintes d'un cancer du sein tout
d'abord j'ai envie de commencer ce cet
entretien avec vous les avez travel où
vous travaillez au centre d'information
sur les droits des femmes et des
familles des yvelines l'association est
créée depuis 1982 c'est bien ça oui ça
fait maintenant 40 ans qu'elle existe
quelles sont les principales difficultés
auxquelles vous êtes confrontés dans
votre métier d'accompagnement des femmes
dans l'emploi
alors moi je travaille essentiellement
sur la commune de magny les hameaux et
montigny les femmes que je reçois sont
surtout des femmes en public d'insertion
avec des qualifie de bas niveaux de
qualification très peu et seules avec
des enfants et du coup elles ont du mal
à jongler entre leur vie de famille et
leur vie professionnelle
donc on est vraiment sur tout ce qui est
les problèmes de l'articulation des
temps
vous recevez aussi des hommes parfois
est ce qu'il ya vraiment une différence
les prêts ne sont pas les mêmes alors
bon au niveau des hommes c'est vrai que
sur la commune où suis-je doit avoir
deux tiers de femmes et un tiers
d'hommes
effectivement quand on discute avec eux
un homme lors d'un entretien très peu
d'employeurs vont lui demander s'il a
des enfants ou s'il en a ils vont
supposée qui a une femme derrière pour
gérer les enfants chose que les femmes
la première des choses qu'on va lui
demander ses des enfants combien en
arrêt ce que la garde est assurée est-ce
qu'il ya du relais au cas où ils sont
malades
on va bien plus poser des questions il
bien plus enquêter de ce côté là à 80
j'envoie réagir c'est quelque chose qui
vous touche également ce nom ça me
paraît
voilà vrai pour tout fait fait une des
inégalités qu'on peut rencontrer mais
bon c'est pas c'est pas rien n'est pas
faisable pour autant mais c'est vrai que
bon ça fait partie des choses qui
existent
on parle aussi vous me parlez également
des problèmes de mobilité
il ya des choses auxquelles les femmes
ne sont plus confrontés alors c'est vrai
que ben le bassin de la ville nouvelle
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines et assez
inégalitaire au niveau de la mine afin
de transports publics entre des communes
comme trame la verrière montigny qui
sont desservis par un pour beaucoup de
transport et des communes comme magny
les hameaux qui sont beaucoup plus
éloignés ils pas des voies de chemin de
fer une erreur il assez près et du coup
la mobilité elle et les transports en
commun sont beaucoup moins fréquents du
coup il faut une voiture personnelle et
je me rends compte que au niveau des
femmes belles investissent peu dans le
permis de conduire en tout cas c'est pas
une priorité alors que chez les hommes
très tout ça devient de prion étaient
des 18 ans et garçons va passer le
permis la famille va payer le permis
alors que chez les jeunes filles
bah ça c'est pas tellement ou alors dans
certaines familles n'êtes pas dans tout
accès à encore mieux vous occuper voilà
deux des fans encore on prend des
preuves juridiques
la situation a quand même évolué quelles
sortes de discriminations auxquels sont
confrontés alors il ya les
discriminations les premières
discrimination quand elle rentre dans le
travail c'est ce dont parlait ma
collègue juste avant c'est la
discrimination à l'embauché
d'abord sur le cv ça on s'est rapidement
si c'est un homme ou si c'est une femme
donc lorsqu'on a déjà un profil vient en
tête c'est facile de faire le tri pour
recevoir le candidat et puis ensuite au
cours de l'entretien on peut vite tomber
sur des questions qui sont interdites
par la loi mais qui sont très courantes
au niveau des employeurs c'est à dire
des questions sur la vie privée
notamment sur les femmes ayant ans est
en âge d'avoir des enfants de savoir
voilà si elle souhaite avoir des enfants
celles qui ont nous comment ça se passe
au niveau des modes de garde
tout ça est en bien sûr des questions
interdites le candidat n'est pas obligé
d'y répondre mais bien sûr s'ils n'y
répondent pas on peut imaginer que les
conséquences pour la suite de l'
embauche fou quand même
assez négative quels conseils vous
donner voilà aux femmes qui sont en
souffrance qui viennent vous voir et qui
sont confrontés à ce genre de problème
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire dans ces cas
là alors il y à différents types de
souffrance 1 on a on a des victimes de
discriminations au sein de leur travail
du fait de leur sexe mais pas que on a
aussi du fait de l'âge du fer voilà de
la couleur de peau et c'est donc tous
ces discriminations elles sont regroupés
ensemble au niveau de la loi
il peut il peut se passer ce qu'on
appelle le harcèlement moral qui est
puni donc la première chose qu'on
encourage c'est d'en parler d'en parler
à son à son employeur lorsque c'est pas
l'employeur directement qui est qui à
l'origine du harcèlement et que c'est
par exemple un collègue ou un solde est
supérieur et d'en parler également à des
associations comme nous médecins du
travail à l'inspection du travail pour
essayer de faire bouger les choses
puisque tout ça ça peut être sanctionné
ça peut il peut y avoir des plaintes il
peut y avoir des procédures au tribunal
et au conseil des prud'hommes
mais bien sûr c'est compliqué c'est un
chemin qui est long et c'est très
souvent décourageant pour pour les
femmes qui subissent du harcèlement que
ce soit morale ou que ça soit sexuelle
tout il faut qu'elle en parle aussi
autour d'elle parce qu'une femme qui est
discriminé ou harcelée sur dans le
milieu du travail il faut se dire qu'on
n'est pas seul et souvent ils ont elles
ont l'impression d'être seuls que c'est
kyle que ça arrive alors que non la
personne elle l'a fait déjà d'autres et
souvent dans discutant se rend compte qu
untel et untel ont déjà subi les mêmes
types de discriminations car oui non
vraiment ça vous fait réagir voilà par
la discrimination par rapport justement
à votre entreprise votre marque des
vêtements
oui justement nous on
n'at on a créé cette cette marque de
lingerie donc pour les femmes atteintes
d'un cancer du sein et qui aussi qui
devient justement aussi après une
discrimination à l'embauché
donc c'est pour ça que nous avons créé
aussi notre entreprise parce qu'on avait
plus de 40 ans toutes les deux une chose
on n'avait pas travaillé depuis de
nombreuses années moi j'ai eu un cancer
du sein donc effectivement sur un cv
bien ça faisait aussi forcément quelque
chose de moins de moins attirant pour un
employeur et donc et en plus on avait
aussi une vocation à faire quelque chose
pour les femmes atteintes d'un cancer du
sein donc voilà le pourquoi de la
création d entreprise vous avez montré
votre entreprise il ya bientôt trois ans
un peu plus c'est ça non pas un petit
peu moins ainsi que moi c'est moi donc à
peu près voilà deux ans et demi du coup
c'est un l'entreprenariat des jeunes se
lancent de plus en plus dans justement
cette aventure elles représentent moins
elles sont moins à la tête de
l'entreprise depuis dix personnes mais
c'est une solution de prendre à quelque
chose puisque un moyen de créer leur
emploi pour vous ça vous a semblé une
évidence était compliqué de se dire on
va je vais monter mon entreprise
nous sommes deux comme ça c'est un petit
peu passé je pense qu'elle 2 justement
on a peut-être un petit peu plus de
culot ou voilà on ose un peu plus est
nous comme vous voulez faire quelque
chose dans deux quand même assez
particulier
je vois pas l'une et l'autre comment on
aurait pu imposer cette envie de créer
de la lingerie
moi je suis pas particulièrement
couturière alors agathe elle a des
compétences dans le domaine dont elle
aurait eu plus de chance mais en fait
l'idée venez demain mon expérience de
malade donc du coup c'était compliqué
d'aller sonner à une porte en disant
voilà je veux faire de la lingerie pour
les femmes options un cancer du sein
j'ai plus de compétences techniques mais
j'avais moins de crédibilité parce que
moi j'ai pas eu ce problème
ce qui est malheureusement le cas de
caroline mais du coup voilà nous ça nous
a le fait de s'associer et dans nos
compétences et dans nos chemins de vie
ça nous a permis d'avoir quelque chose
de dentier et de qui tiennent un peu la
rampe quoi ça va donner plus de force à
ce que l'une santos avait lancé
également cette aventure pas à la pâte
dans quelque chose de filles non non non
ce que nous on fait de la fabrication
fait fabriquer non pas ça ça reste quand
même assez compliqué c'est pas un
service où c'est pas juste de la revente
de quelque chose qu'on achète donc c'est
c'est quand même un peu un peu compliqué
de mettre en plein vent tueur est
compliqué ce que vous conseilleriez aux
femmes voilà qui veulent se lancer alesi
vraiment c'est une bonne expérience
est ce qu'il ya des pinceaux quand il
faut être vraiment faim faire attention
a dit vigilant vigilant je sais pas mais
le conseiller oui fin de toute évidence
c'est extrêmement intéressant évidemment
on touche à plein de choses diverses et
variées ça change tout le temps et en
plus quand on est deux on se soutient
mutuellement quant à la petite baisse de
régime fait un enfant c'est très
valorisant en fait c'est très valorisant
et pays
et puis ça amène aussi une expérience
qu'ont secret soi même qui peut être
après utilisable
par la suite je ne sais pas si le corps
des femmes sont plus jeunes puisque nous
ment gêne mais ça peut être ça peut être
quelque chose de franchement utile je
puis ça donne aussi de l'assurance et en
fait au départ quand on se lance dans
l'aventuré
on y va je pense qu'il faut pas trop se
poser de questions il faut que le projet
quand même et et soit soit concret et un
quelconque intérêt
mais après les choses se font au fur et
à mesure et et on apprend et après on va
aussi sonner aux portes et on demande de
l'aide aussi un peu à droite et un rejet
vous conseillez également gesa aux
femmes de se lancer dans cette aventure
tout les deux c'était comme ça que vous
apportez aussi souvent c'est vrai que
c'est ce que vous disiez c'est surtout
le manque de confiance on a beaucoup de
femmes qui sont vraiment de confiance
d'abord parce que l on pu avoir des
trous dans leur cv avoir des difficultés
dans leur travail avoir subi des choses
voilà au niveau de leurs anciens
employeurs qui font qu'elles ont perdu
toute cette confiance là c'est un vrai
travail
voilà pour remobiliser la confiance
épuisé
et puis avoir confiance en soi dans le
sens on le voit bien sur les chiffres là
je les ai pas en tête mais je crois
qu'il ya beaucoup moins de femmes ça
j'en suis sûr d'où trois fois moins de
femmes qui créent des entreprises que
des hommes par contre les femmes qui
créent les entreprises au bout de cinq
ans elles sont beaucoup plus viable que
celle des hommes
oui car là les chiffres sont flagrants
et elle y réfléchisse à deux fois et
celles qui se lancent dans l'aventuré
souvent elles ont des projets beaucoup
plus ficelé beaucoup mieux construit et
l'entreprise devient plus fiables il ya
justement aussi des initiatives pour la
compagnie vous avez bénéficié des
trophées du lauréat des trophées
d'entrepreneuriat au féminin c'est ça je
ne sais pas la cgpme voilà ceux des amis
ce qu'ils vous ont aidé qui vous ennuie
au pouce et peut-être donner confiance
aussi oui tout à fait
on est déjà toujours un peu ravi d'être
d'être repérés et de d'être félicités
gérer pour notre travail et encourager
parce que nous on a eu le trophée de
l'encouragement et en avait bien besoin
et donc aux étés c'était mais c'est
toujours gratifiant et et ça nous a
permis effectivement de faire des
rencontres
2 voilà deux d'élargir notre réseau ce
qui est très important dans une dans une
entreprise bien il ya des initiatives
comme ça qu'ils encouragent les femmes
vers l'emploi vers l'entrepreneuriat et
voilà on doit les saluer et justement si
vous êtes intéressé par la seconde
édition des trophées l'entrepreneuriat
au féminin organisé par la cgpme
sachez qu'une réunion est organisée ce
lundi 19 mars au siège de la cgpme à
rambouillet pour aider toutes les
candidates qui veulent une paix stable
pour remplir leurs dossiers donc le
rendez vous c'est de 10h à 12h et de 14h
à 18h au siège de la cgpme à rambouillet
il ya madame merci d'être venu sur notre
plateau et d'avoir répondu à toutes nos
questions
nous continuons notre émission sur les
femmes et le monde de l'entreprise avec
le chiffre de la semaine passée tout de
suite
8,5 pour cent c'est le pourcentage de
l'écart de rémunération brute entre les
femmes et les hommes dans le privé et à
poste équivalent pour l'année 2013 ce
constat est tiré d'une vaste enquête
menée auprès de 14 mille cadres et
publié cette semaine par l'apec
l'association pour l'emploi des cadres
à noter aussi que d'après cette étude le
niveau de diplôme ne protège pas du
phénomène d'écart de salaire mais le
réduit tout même et nous restons sur
l'entrepreneuriat au féminin avec
l'entreprise de la semaine
et cette semaine nous vous proposons de
revenir sur le parcours d'une chef
d'entreprise yvelinoise nathalie leroy
habite à montigny le bretonneux
elle a créé son entreprise en 2009 une
société de services pour aider les
expatriés à s'installer sur le
territoire évinois et en ile de france
regardez son portrait les images de
pâtre grec dixmude il y à presque 6 ans
nous suivions nathalie leroy elle
accueillait sa première cliente
américaine à saint quentin en yvelines
c'est yvelinoise ancien ingénieur chez
renault s'est lancé dans la relocation
en 2009 elle a fondé il exploite une
entreprise de services pour aider les
expatriés à s'installer
je savais que le début serait pas facile
financièrement mais ce n'est pas une
surprise
ça a été conforme aux prévisions elle
donc tout allait bien et puis du coup
après ça s'est développé plus que ce que
j'avais espéré au début en régime de
croisière
puisqu'on a réussi à intégrer des
prestations qui n'était pas prévu au
départ
aujourd'hui nathalie prend en charge
l'installation de plusieurs dizaines de
clients chaque année
pour cela elle a multiplié ses services
et s'est entouré de plusieurs
collaborateurs des prestataires toute
féminine un hasard selon nathalie la
mixité est plutôt souhaitable parce que
ça permet d'avoir des approches
différentes des points de vue différents
après on s'entend bien on écoute très
efficace peut-être ce qui différencie
les femmes c'est pas que ce souci
d'efficacité plus que l'apparence et on
va chercher à avoir un résultat sans
forcément se faire valoir
c'est à ce qui caractérise plus les
femmes parmi ces cinq collaboratrice
marie-laure crépon elles se sont
rencontrées dans le club des femmes
entrepreneurs des yvelines créactive
basée à promo paul doux nathalie a été
la présidente pendant plusieurs années
ancien salarié marie-laure connaît bien
le statut d'expatrié pour avoir vécu
plusieurs années en asie aujourd'hui
elle transmet son savoir sur les
habitudes culturelles françaises pour
une expats chaque personne peut avoir
des besoins particuliers ou des peurs
particulière c'est à dire si vous prenez
un japonais
il sait que les français fonctionne de
manière très différents qui va avoir une
perception déjà d'emblée de cette
différence dont qui il va craindre
beaucoup de choses donc une formation
interculturelle ça a aussi pour objectif
de rassurer de dire
voilà il ya des moyens de travailler
ensemble après un parcours professionnel
riche marie laure a voulu devenir son
propre patron
on est beaucoup plus responsable aussi
de tout le côté administratif gestion
gestion des donc oui ça demande une
bonne organisation sa demande du tonus
parce qu'il faut tout gérer quand même
en il faut gérer aussi le côté privé
enfin de toute façon ça c'est le dilemme
permanent inexpertes continue sur sa
voix nathalie leroy espère continuer à
développer sa société en france elles
sont de plus en plus nombreuses à se
lancer dans l'entrepreneuriat pour créer
leur emploi
un fait qui ne se vérifie pas dans les
plus grosses entreprises seulement 11 %
des pme pmi sont exclusivement dirigées
par des femmes en les maintenant temps
de passer à notre métier la semaine
cette semaine nous sommes intéressés au
métier d'archiviste pour consulter des
documents administratifs et on sen est
fou se rendent aux archers la
départementale 7 des yvelines se situe à
montigny le bretonneux 28 personnes y
travaillent dont une majorité de femmes
regardez ce reportage réalisé avec
romain on finit là ce sont des comptes
si elle manie ses documents avec
précaution c'est qu'ils représentent le
coeur de son activité
brigitte buc et est archiviste entre
enquêtrice et conservatrice elle fait
des recherches parmi les milliers de
documents à disposition pour satisfaire
les demandes administratives judiciaires
ou personnel on a plusieurs types de
demandes des recherches militaires donc
qu'on appelle des registres matricules
les jugements de divorce des successions
des jugements d'adoption des recherches
des crocs de personnes qui
ceci à mon donné de leur vie et qui se
sont retrouvés en prison
on leur fournit des informations quand
on nous demande on fait un petit peu de
tout c'est ce qui rend le travail
agréable parce que c'est jamais la même
chose
brigitte nous l'assurent pas de chômage
chez les archivistes
auparavant elle était comptable beaucoup
de ses collègues ont travaillé comme
elle dans d'autres secteurs avant les
archives il n'y a pas qu'une filière
pour entrer dans la profession moi je
suis à la base un sap et de comptabilité
et un service de secrétariat
ce qui n'existe plus de nos jours nous
avons tous des parcours très différents
les uns des autres
à part les vrais professionnels des
archivistes où ils ont un diplôme
d'archiviste beaucoup ont des licences
eu d'histoire où on fait des masters des
archives tout simplement et nous ici aux
archives départementales
nous avons un partenariat avec les
archives des hauts-de-seine où là nous
faisons un masseur suisse tic master 2
des visites et ateliers sont souvent
organisées afin de faire connaître le
travail fait ici une trentaine de
personnes travaillent dans
l'établissement bibliothécaire
photographe chargé de mise en ligne
il faut du monde pour préserver le
patrimoine historique yvelinois stockés
dans ces grandes salles réfrigérées
ça ce sont des arrêtés de préfecture qui
date de 1862 en 1894
en fait ce sont des séances qui ont eu
lieu mais ça concerne quelques affaires
des dizaines de personnes viennent
chaque jour aux archives départementales
des yvelines située à montigny le
bretonneux
les archivistes sont aussi en contact
avec eux ils sont là pour les orienter
un lien entre le présent et le passé
nous avons beaucoup de gens qui viennent
en salle de lecture pour consulter
justement leur généalogie familiale très
souvent ça démarre par l'histoire de la
maison et après ben y viennent pour
consulter l'histoire de la famille mais
il ya aussi une chose qui est importante
c'est que aux archives départementales
nous avons la chance d'avoir beaucoup de
numérisation qui a été fait qui est en
cours et qui est en prévision
ce qui fait que les gens même s'ils sont
un signe mais à los angeles ou à moscou
ils peuvent consulter leur généalogie
par internet avec internet le métier ce
modernisme et le rôle des archivistes
reste primordiale l'année dernière
environ vingt mille personnes se sont
rendues dans les salles de lecture et
près de 10 mille demandes ont été
enregistrées
c'est la fin notre émission merci de
nous avoir suivis je vous donne rendez
vous la semaine prochaine pour un
prochain numéro de fil échos je vous
souhaite une très bonne soirée